أنا فقط لا أرى
بايدن يفعل ذلك من طاقم جسدي أو
عقلي، نعم لا أرى ذلك
[موسيقى]
إنه الآن في أيرلندا ولن
يعقد مؤتمرًا صحفيًا  عندما ينفجر العالم،
أملك عقارًا في أيرلندا، لن أذهب
إلى أيرلندا، العالم ينفجر من حولنا،
يمكن أن ينتهي بك الأمر في حرب عالمية ثالثة
وهذا الرجل سيكون في أيرلندا
[موسيقى]
كثيرًا ما أقول
إنهم قالوا لي  في أحد الأيام،
قال أحد زملائك الصحفيين من هي
المشكلة الأكبر، إذًا هل هي الصين؟ هل
يمكن أن تكون روسيا؟ هل يمكن أن تكون
كوريا الشمالية؟ لا. قلت إن المشكلة الأكبر هي
من الداخل،
هؤلاء الأشخاص المتطرفون المرضى
من الداخل لأننا نستطيع التعامل معها إذا
كنا  أذكياء يمكننا التعامل مع روسيا الصين
لقد فعلت ذلك
[موسيقى]
شكرًا لك
ألقِ نظرة على المملكة
العربية السعودية وانظر إلى ما حدث،
إنهم أناس رائعون
يريدون مساعدتنا
[موسيقى]